das könnte wirklich die lösung sein
künftige siedler auf dem mars brauchen
etwas zu essen da führt kein weg daran
vorbei doch der boden des roten planeten
ist extrem lebensfeindlich pflanzen und
mikroorganismen können hier unmöglich
gedeihen
das ultraleichte material namens aero
gilt könnte den pflanzenanbau auf dem
mars aber dennoch möglich machen und das
funktioniert nach einem einfachen aber
genialen prinzip klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt es täglich
faszinierendes seien sie abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen auch wenn der rote planet der
erde in gewissen dingen elend ist seine
oberfläche alles andere als
lebensfreundlich wasser verdampft hier
sofort dafür ist der geringe luftdruck
von rund sieben minibagger
verantwortlich super gefährlich ist aber
auch die schädliche ultraviolet und
partikel strahlung der sonne bedingt
durch die sehr dünne atmosphäre erreicht
sie die mars oberfläche fast
uneingeschränkt die folge im boden des
roten planeten entstehen unheimlich
aggressive stoffe wie beispielsweise
peroxide und perchlorat leben ist somit
nicht möglich denn die dafür notwendigen
organischen verbindungen werden direkt
durch diese aggressiven stoffe zerstört
der anbau von pflanzen der für eine maß
kolonisation extrem wichtig wäre
gestaltet sich somit als unmöglich doch
die nasa hat einen plan wie dieses
problem gelöst werden könnte eine
entscheidende rolle könnte dabei das
ultraleichte material namens aerogele
spielen schon jetzt macht die nasa es
sich zunutze und zwar als isolator bei
den mars rover unglaublich in 99 prozent
des volumens sind nichts also leerer
raum
ansonsten besteht es aus einem see
descartes das material ist ein guter
isolator und ganz besonders leicht seine
dichte entspricht der dichte von glas zu
weniger als einem tausendstel und
dennoch handelt es sich um ein festes
material und das aero gehen kann noch
mehr das ultraviolette licht also das uv
licht wird blockiert sichtbares licht
dagegen wird von ihm hindurch gelassen
ein perfekter baustoff also um eine art
gewächshaus auf dem mars zu errichten
das hat sich auch ein forschungsteam von
der harvard university gedacht durch die
umsetzung dieser idee könnten künftige
maas sieht also pflanzen auf dem roten
planeten anbauen und später ernten und
essen dazu die nasa geologin
kerber die studie war als erster test
für die möglichkeiten eines aero gels
als baumaterial für den mars gedacht das
experiment lieferte erfolgversprechend
ergebnisse auf einer oberfläche wurde
eine zwei zentimeter die geschichte
aerogel aufgetragen und mit einer lampe
beleuchtet diese sollte das sonnenlicht
auf dem roten planeten simulieren die
darunterliegende oberfläche erwerben der
sich tatsächlich um 65 grad celsius
somit würde also bereits eine zwei bis
drei zentimeter dicke eisschicht auf dem
mars boden nicht nur für einen guten
schutz vor der schädlichen strahlung
sorgen zudem würde das material dazu
führen dass die temperatur unter der
verdeckten oberfläche um rund 50 grad
celsius ansteigt dem treibhauseffekt
seien dank der ogh das sichtbare licht
fast ungehindert durch lässt und die
energiereiche uv strahlung absorbiert
wird diese in wärme umgewandelt
wassereis haltiger untergrund auf dem
mars würde so aufgeheizt was flüssiges
wasser im boden zur folge hätte
dieses wiederum würde mit den
aggressiven stoffen reagieren ebenso wie
mit den mineralien im boden dies würde
nicht nur pflanzen sondern auch
mikroorganismen zu gute kommen falls
dieser plan aufgeht wäre dies eine
absolute erleichterung für künftige maß
siedler und zudem eine deutlich
einfachere angelegenheit als das viel
diskutierte terraforming über das war ja
hier schon bald ging es um
science-fiction berichtet haben hier
müsste er ja die gesamte mars oberfläche
der lufthülle der erde angepasst werden
eine idee deren umsetzbarkeit von vielen
fachleuten übrigens extrem bezweifelt
wird auf den einsatz von aerogele haben
das nasa forschungsteam übrigens durch
die dunklen flecken auf der mars
oberfläche dieses gefrorenem
kohlendioxid ist nämlich genau wie das
aerogel nicht durchlässig so dass der
boden darunter durch das sonnenlicht
erwärmt wird so sammelt sich hier
gasförmige kohlendioxid das durch seine
ausdehnung letztendlich dazu führt dass
das eis platzt gas wird frei und
befördert dunkle erde an die oberfläche
sehr cool wie ideen manchmal entstehen
leben wir bald auf dem mars anklicken
also hier anschauen und doktor watson
abonnieren super kanal den ich unbedingt
empfehle bis dann bleibt dran